Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. When Dennis Nielsen moved out of his flat at 195 Melrose Avenue in Cricklewood, he had already taken the lives of 12 victims. By Monday, November 23, 1981, he had been living in his new flat at 23 Cranley Gardens in Muswell Hill for seven weeks and was eager to put the pass behind him and start afresh. It was his 36th birthday and to celebrate,
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序上或我们网站上的本集节目说明。当丹尼斯·尼尔森（Dennis Nielsen）搬出他在克里克伍德梅尔罗斯大道195号的公寓时，他已经夺去了12名受害者的生命。到1981年11月23日星期一，他在马斯韦尔山克兰利花园23号的新公寓里已经住了七周，急于将过去抛在脑后，重新开始。那天是他的36岁生日，为了庆祝，
he took the day off work and headed out to the pub. As his new home was only five miles from his old address, he continued to frequent many of his usual drinking horns. At 1.30pm, Nielsen was drinking in the Golden Lion pub on Dean Street in Soho when he struck up a conversation with Paul Nobs, a 19-year-old undergrad who was studying Slavonic and Eastern European studies at the University of London. Paul was supposed to be attending a lecture, but had decided to take the afternoon off to buy some books. Nielsen was impressed by Paul's intelligence and the two chatted for an hour until Paul announced that he needed to go to the bookstore. Nielsen accompanied him there and invited Paul back to his flat for dinner afterwards.
他请了一天假，去了一家酒吧。由于他的新家距离旧住所只有五英里，他继续光顾许多他常去的喝酒场所。下午1:30，尼尔森正在苏荷区迪恩街的“金狮”酒吧喝酒，这时他与19岁的本科生保罗·诺布斯（Paul Nobs）搭话，保罗当时在伦敦大学攻读斯拉夫和东欧研究。保罗本该去上课，但决定请个下午假去买几本书。尼尔森对保罗的才华印象深刻，两人聊了一个小时，直到保罗宣布他需要去书店。尼尔森陪他去了那里，并邀请保罗随后去他的公寓吃晚饭。
Paul accepted the invitation and they stopped at a nearby supermarket to purchase some chops and liquor, arriving back at 23 Cranley Gardens at around 5.45pm. The three-story residence was once a single family home, but had since been split into a multi-tenant building. Its owner didn't live on site, instead hiring the services of local real estate agency Ellison Co. to manage the property and its tenants. In addition to Dennis Nielsen, there were four other tenants living in the building. The ground floor was divided into two flats, one of which was occupied by a builder named Jim Alcock and his bartender girlfriend Fiona Bridges. The other was leased to two young women, a dental nurse from New Zealand named Vivian McStay and a youth worker from Holland named
保罗接受了邀请，他们在附近的超市停下来买了一些排骨和烈酒，大约下午5点45分回到克兰利花园23号。这座三层住宅曾经是一栋单户住宅，但后来被分割成了一栋多住户建筑。房东并不住在现场，而是聘请当地房地产机构埃利森公司（Ellison Co.）的服务来管理该物业及其租户。除了丹尼斯·尼尔森外，楼里还住着其他四位租户。底楼被分为两套公寓，其中一套住着一名叫吉姆·奥尔科克（Jim Alcock）的建筑工人及其担任酒保的女友菲奥娜·布里奇斯（Fiona Bridges）。另一套租给了两位年轻女性，一位是来自新西兰的牙科护士维维安·麦克斯特伊（Vivian McStay），另一位是来自荷兰的青年工作者
Manig Venruta. The first floor was unoccupied. Nielsen lived on the top floor in a small squalid attic space that was accessed via two flights of stairs. Its front door opened to a small grimy hallway that served as a kitchen with a small cupboard, gastove and sink to the left, as well as a door that led directly to a grubby bathroom. To the right of the hallway were two doors, one that opened onto a living room containing wardrobes, two armchairs and a tea chest and another that led to Nielsen's disorganized bedroom. A double bed sat in the middle of the room with a small sofa to its right, along with a television, stereo, several pot plants and other rods and ends. Each room had sloping ceilings and dull brown carpets that were simply laid on
马尼格·温鲁塔（Manig Venruta）。二楼无人居住。尼尔森住在顶楼一个小而肮脏的阁楼空间里，需要穿过两段楼梯才能到达。其前门通向一条狭小、污秽的走廊，走廊左侧有一个小橱柜、燃气灶和水槽，还有一扇通往肮脏浴室的门。走廊右侧有两扇门，一扇通往起居室，里面有衣柜、两把扶手椅和一个茶箱，另一扇通往尼尔森凌乱的卧室。房间正中间放着一张双人床，右侧有一个小沙发，还有一台音响、几盆植物以及其他杂物。每个房间都有倾斜的天花板，铺着暗棕色的地毯，地毯只是简单地铺在
top of the floor instead of fitted into place. When Nielsen and Paul Nobbs arrived at the flat, Nielsen cooked them dinner and the two sat down to drink and watch television. Paul called his mother to let her know he'd be home shortly, but he then started feeling sick from all the alcohol and phoned her back to say he would be spending the night at a friend's place. The two men eventually undressed, hopped into Nielsen's bed and started kissing, but they were both tired and soon fell asleep. At 2 a.m. Paul woke up feeling nauseated with a throbbing headache. He went to the kitchen, poured himself a glass of water and sat on the couch for a while. Nielsen got up to check on him
地板表面，而不是固定到位的。当尼尔森和保罗·诺布斯到达公寓时，尼尔森为他们做了晚饭，两人坐下来喝酒看电视。保罗给母亲打了电话，告知她自己很快就会回家，但随后他开始因为喝了太多酒而感到恶心，于是又回电话说他要在朋友家过夜。两个男人最终脱掉衣服，跳上尼尔森的床并开始接吻，但他们都很累，很快就睡着了。凌晨2点，保罗醒来，感到恶心，并伴随着一阵阵剧烈的头痛。他走到厨房，给自己倒了一杯水，在沙发上坐了一会儿。尼尔森起身查看他的情况，
and they both went back to bed. At 6 a.m. Paul woke again and went back to the kitchen, which had a mirror above the sink. Upon catching a glimpse of his reflection, Paul realized that his face was red and bruised and his eyes were bloodshot. His hands were shaking uncontrollably, his throat hurt and there was a deep red mark across his neck. When Nielsen saw Paul, he remarked, God, you look awful, and suggested that he see a doctor. He then wrote down his address and told Paul that he hoped they would see one another again. Paul staggered away from Nielsen's flat and made his way to the University of London for
然后两人都回到了床上。早上6点，保罗再次醒来，回到厨房，厨房的水槽上方有一面镜子。当瞥见自己的倒影时，保罗发现自己的脸又红又肿，布满血丝。他的双手无法控制地颤抖，喉咙疼痛，脖子上有一道深深的红印。尼尔森看到保罗时，评论道：“天哪，你看起来糟透了，”并建议他去看医生。随后，他写下了自己的地址，并告诉保罗，他希望他们能再次见面。保罗蹒跚着离开尼尔森的公寓，前往伦敦大学上
his scheduled classes. One of his tutors noticed that he looked incredibly unwell and immediately booked him an appointment at the University College Hospital around the corner from the campus. At the clinic, Paul's hands shook so badly that he knocked over a cup of coffee and was unable to light a cigarette. The doctor gave him a tranquilizer to calm his nerves and after conducting a checkup, deemed that Paul's symptoms were consistent with having pain strangled. Although Paul Knobbs realized that Dennis Nielsen must have attacked him in his sleep and then acted as though nothing had ever happened, he decided not to report the incident to the
预定的课程。他的一位导师注意到他脸色极其难看，立刻为他预约了校园转角处的大学学院医院。在诊所里，保罗的手抖得太厉害，以至于打翻了一杯咖啡，连烟都点不着。医生给了他镇静剂来平静神经，在进行了检查后，认为保罗的症状与遭受绞杀相符。尽管保罗·诺布斯意识到丹尼斯·尼尔森一定是在他睡着时袭击了他，然后又装作什么都没发生过一样，但他决定不将此事报告给
police. To explain the mark that remained visible across his neck for the next three months, he told others that he had been attacked during a mugging. Paul spotted Nielsen at the Golden Lion about a year after the incident but avoided speaking to him. In March 1982, four months after the attack on Paul Knobbs, Nielsen was drinking at the Salisbury on St Martin's Lane, London's pre-eminent gay bar, when he ran into 28-year-old John Howlett, whom Nielsen knew as John the Guardsman. The two had met at another pub a couple of months earlier, where John had boasted of being an ex-Grenadier Guardsman and they had chatted over drinks for a couple of hours. John had lived a troubled life. At the age of 13, he was kicked out of his family
警察。为了解释在接下来三个月里依然清晰可见地留在脖子上的印记，他告诉别人自己是在一次抢劫中遭到袭击的。大约在事件发生一年后，保罗在“金狮”酒吧发现了尼尔森，但避免与他说话。1982年3月，在对保罗·诺布斯的袭击发生四个月后，尼尔森正在伦敦首屈一指的同性恋酒吧——圣马丁巷的“索尔兹伯里”酒吧喝酒，当时他遇到了28岁的约翰·霍利特（John Howlett），尼尔森称他为“近卫军约翰”。两人几个月前在另一家酒吧相识，当时约翰曾吹嘘自己是一名退役近卫掷弹兵，他们在喝东西时聊了几个小时。约翰度过了一段坎坷的人生。13岁时，他被踢出了家族
home and spent his adolescence living in group residences, where he was constantly in trouble with the police. As an adult, John had served time in prison for theft and made ends meet by working in travelling fairgrounds. At the Salisbury, John recognised Nielsen and joined him for a drink at the bar. The service was slow, which frustrated Nielsen and he suggested they go to his flat to drink instead. John agreed and the pair walked to a liquor store to stock up on alcohol before catching the tube back to 23 Cranley Gardens. There, Nielsen cooked dinner and the two settled in to drink and watch television in the living room. As midnight approached, John asked if he could rest his head for a while. Nielsen agreed and continued watching TV while John left to lie
住宅，整个青春期都在集体宿舍里度过，期间不断与警方发生冲突。成年后，约翰曾因盗窃入狱服刑，靠在流动游乐场工作维持生计。在“索尔兹伯里”酒吧，约翰认出了尼尔森，并加入他在吧台喝了一杯。服务很慢，这让尼尔森感到沮丧，他建议两人去他的公寓喝酒。约翰同意了，两人走到一家酒类专卖店囤积了酒，然后坐地铁回到了克兰利花园23号。在那里，尼尔森做好了晚饭，两人在起居室安顿下来喝酒看电视。随着午夜临近，约翰问他是否可以躺一会儿。尼尔森同意了，继续看电视，而约翰则去
down in the bedroom. At around 1am, Nielsen went to the bedroom and found John lying half naked and asleep in his bed. He woke him and commented, I thought you were getting your head down, I didn't know you were moving in. Nielsen offered to call John a taxi, but John said he didn't feel like getting up. This frustrated Nielsen as he didn't find John attractive and no longer wanted him in his flat. He poured himself another glass of rum and sat on the edge of the bed, contemplating what to do next. Eventually, Nielsen retrieved a strap of material from underneath an armchair, straddled John's body, and tied the material around his neck, remarking, it's about time you went. A furious struggle ensued, during which Nielsen struck John's head
卧室躺下。大约凌晨1点，尼尔森走到卧室，发现约翰半裸着身子在床上睡着了。他叫醒约翰并评论道：“我还以为你只是躺一会儿，没想到你要搬进来。”尼尔森提出为约翰叫辆出租车，但约翰说他不想起来。这让尼尔森感到沮丧，因为他并不觉得约翰有吸引力，也不再希望他在自己的公寓里。他给自己又倒了一杯朗姆酒，坐在床边，思索着下一步该怎么办。最终，尼尔森从一把扶手椅底下抽出一根带状物，跨坐在约翰的身上，把带状物系在他的脖子上，并说道：“你也该上路了。”随后爆发了一场激烈的争斗，在此期间，尼尔森将约翰的头部撞击在
against the edge of the headrest, drawing blood. John continued to fight back, but soon fell off the bed and lost consciousness. Nielsen tightened the material around John's neck until he was sure he was dead. Nielsen's dog, Bleep, was barking frantically in the next room, so he went to comfort her. When he returned to the bedroom a few minutes later, he discovered that John was still breathing. Nielsen strangled him again, then dragged him into the bathroom, filled the tub with water, and held John's head down until he was no longer breathing. Nielsen left him there as he changed the sheets on his bed, and then went to sleep with Bleep, curled up by his feet. The following morning, Nielsen hid John's body in his wardrobe. Three days later,
头枕的边缘，导致流血。约翰继续反抗，但很快从床上摔下来并失去了意识。尼尔森收紧了套在约翰脖子上的带子，直到确定他已经死亡。尼尔森的狗“哔哔”（Bleep）在隔壁房间疯狂吠叫，于是他去安抚它。几分钟后他回到卧室，发现约翰还在呼吸。尼尔森再次勒住他的脖子，然后将他拖进浴室，浴缸里蓄满水，按住约翰的头直到他不再呼吸。尼尔森把尸体留在那里，换了床单，然后和蜷缩在脚边的“哔哔”一起睡去。第二天早上，尼尔森将约翰的尸体藏在衣柜里。三天后，
he covered his bathroom floor with garbage bags, retrieved the body, and began dismembering it. To dispose of the organs, he cut them into pieces and flushed them down the toilet. This proved to be a time-consuming process, so he attempted to speed things up by boiling the flesh and organs into a soup-like consistency that was easier to flush. Once the bones of the hands, feet, and ribs were free of flesh, he broke them apart and placed them in his regular rubbish bin to be tossed out with the rest of his household waste. Nielsen packed the bigger bones, including the skull, arms, legs, and pelvis, into several garbage bags along with salt and padding, and stored them in the tea chest in the corner of his living room. Two months later, in May 1982, Nielsen was
他用垃圾袋铺满浴室地板，取回尸体，开始将其分尸。为了处理内脏，他把它们切成小块，冲进马桶。事实证明这是一个耗时的过程，于是他试图通过将肉和内脏煮成类似汤的稠度来加速这一过程，这样更容易冲走。一旦手、脚和肋骨上的骨头没有了肉，他就把它们砸碎，扔进普通的垃圾桶里，和家里的其他垃圾一起处理掉。尼尔森将较大的骨头，包括头骨、手臂、腿和骨盆，连同盐和填充物一起塞进几个垃圾袋中，并存放在起居室角落的茶箱里。两个月后，即1982年5月，尼尔森正在
drinking at a gay bar in Camden called the Black Cap when he noticed a young blond man drinking alone. The man had several red marks on his face, and Nielsen approached to ask about his injuries. The man introduced himself as 21-year-old Carl Stodder and explained that he had just escaped from an abusive boyfriend. His facial wounds were carpet burns from the most recent attack, and he was drinking to distract himself. Nielsen smiled and reassured Carl that he was still attractive despite his injuries. Carl was struck by Nielsen's kindness, and the two began chatting, bonding over the shared alienation they felt from their families. When the Black Cap closed, Nielsen invited Carl back to his flat. He accepted, and they caught a cab, holding hands throughout
卡姆登的一家名为“黑帽”（Black Cap）的同性恋酒吧喝酒，这时他注意到一个金发年轻男子独自一人喝酒。这名男子的脸上有几处红印，尼尔森走上前去询问他的伤势。男子自我介绍说自己是21岁的卡尔·斯托德（Carl Stodder），并解释说他刚从一个虐待他的男友那里逃出来。他脸上的伤是最近一次袭击留下的地毯擦伤，他正在喝酒以转移注意力。尼尔森微笑着安慰卡尔，说他尽管受了伤依然很有吸引力。卡尔对尼尔森的善良感到震惊，两人开始聊天，因他们对家庭感到的共同疏离感而产生了共鸣。当“黑帽”酒吧打烊时，尼尔森邀请卡尔回他的公寓。他接受了，两人拦了一辆出租车，
the ride. Nielsen didn't approve of the route the driver chose to take them home, and became unusually angry, retaliating by paying with the smallest change possible. Once they arrived at 23 Cranley Gardens, the two men drank heavily while listening to music. At one point, Nielsen insisted Carl listen to his favorite song using headphones, and stood behind him as he did so, watching intently. They became affectionate, but Carl told Nielsen he didn't feel like having sex. Carl eventually had too much to drink and felt ill, so they decided to go to bed. Nielsen pointed out that the sleeping bag on his bed had a loose zipper, and warned Carl to be careful not to get caught in it. About an hour later, Carl woke up suddenly when he felt a sharp
一路上手拉着手。尼尔森对司机选择的回家路线很不满意，变得异常愤怒，并以支付最小面额的零钱作为报复。一到达克兰利花园23号，两个男人一边听音乐一边痛饮。有一段时间，尼尔森坚持要卡尔戴上耳机听他最喜欢的歌，并在他听的时候站在他身后专注地看着。他们变得亲昵起来，但卡尔告诉尼尔森他不想做爱。卡尔最终喝得太多，感到恶心，于是他们决定上床睡觉。尼尔森指出他床上的睡袋拉链坏了，并警告卡尔小心不要被卡住。大约一个小时后，卡尔突然醒来，感到脖子上一阵剧痛和窒息感。
pain and sense of tightness around his neck. Nielsen was behind him, pulling on the sleeping bag, warning Carl to stay still. Thinking he was caught in the zipper and that Nielsen was trying to help him out, Carl struggled to set himself free, but soon lost consciousness. When he came to, he could hear water running, and felt incredibly cold. Quote, I knew I was in the water, and he was trying to drown me. He kept pushing me into the water. The third time I came up, I said, no more, please, no more. And he pushed me under again. I just thought I was dying. I thought this man was killing me, and I was dying. I thought, you were drowning, this is what it feels like to die.
尼尔森在他身后，拉着睡袋，警告卡尔不要动。卡尔以为自己被拉链卡住了，尼尔森在帮他解围，于是挣扎着想脱身，但很快失去了意识。当他醒来时，他听到流水声，并感到极其寒冷。“我知道我在水里，他在试图淹死我。他一直把我往水里按。第三次我浮上来时，我说，不要了，求求你，不要了。他又把我按了下去。我当时以为自己要死了。我觉得这个人正在杀我，而我在死去。我想，你在溺水，这就是濒死的感觉。”
I felt very relaxed, and I passed out. I couldn't fight anymore. Assuming that Carl was now dead, Nielsen carried him out of the bath and placed him on the living room floor. His dog, Bleep, then started licking Carl's face, which alerted Nielsen to the fact that he was still alive. Seemingly changing his mind about murdering Carl, he spent the next few hours attempting to revive him and warming him up. Carl eventually regained consciousness, but was dazed and disorientated, and had trouble remembering what had happened. He saw his reflection, and realized there was a deep red mark around his neck, and broken blood vessels all over his face and in his eyes.
“我感到非常放松，然后昏了过去。我再也无力反抗了。”尼尔森以为卡尔已经死了，便把他从浴缸里抱出来，放在起居室的地板上。他的狗“哔哔”随后开始舔卡尔的脸，这提醒了尼尔森他还活着。尼尔森似乎改变了杀害卡尔的主意，接下来的几个小时里，他试图让卡尔苏醒并帮他取暖。卡尔最终恢复了意识，但神志不清、迷失方向，记不清发生了什么。他看到自己的倒影，发现脖子上有一道深深的红印，脸上和眼睛里到处都是破裂的毛细血管。
Nielsen explained that Carl had been caught in a sleeping bag zipper and lost consciousness, and that he had splashed water onto Carl's face to wake him up. In a state of shock, Carl believed Nielsen, who spent the morning comforting him. When Carl started to feel slightly better, Nielsen walked him to a nearby tube station and gave him his name and address in case he wanted to remain in contact. Carl made his way to the Royal Free Hospital in Hampstead, roughly three miles from Nielsen's flat, and told a doctor there that he'd been caught in a zipper. The doctor was adamant that Carl's injuries were consistent with having been strangled, and concluded that someone may have tried to kill him.
尼尔森解释说，卡尔是被睡袋拉链卡住而失去了意识，他是把水泼在卡尔脸上才把他叫醒的。处于震惊状态的卡尔相信了尼尔森，尼尔森花了一早上的时间安慰他。当卡尔开始感觉好点时，尼尔森陪他走到附近的地铁站，并留下了自己的名字和地址，以防他以后想保持联系。卡尔前往距离尼尔森公寓大约三英里的汉普斯特德皇家自由医院，并告诉那里的医生他被拉链卡住了。医生坚信卡尔的伤势符合被勒死的特征，并推断可能有人试图杀害他。
But Carl, still in a state of shock, was uncertain what to believe. Around the time of the attack on Carl's daughter, Nielsen applied for another promotion at the Job Center, but was once again denied. He wrote a letter to his personnel manager, saying that he felt victimized and asked what was preventing him from moving up the ladder. Nielsen was subsequently invited to appeal the decision and succeeded. After eight years of service, he was finally promoted to the role of executive officer. On June 28, 1982, Nielsen was reassigned to the Kentish Town Job Center branch, located approximately three and a half miles from his flat in Muswell Hill.
但卡尔仍然处于震惊状态，不确定该相信什么。在对卡尔实施袭击的这段时间里，尼尔森申请了就业中心的另一次晋升，但再次被拒绝。他给人事经理写了一封信，称自己感到遭到迫害，并询问是什么阻碍了他晋升。尼尔森随后被邀请对该决定进行上诉并获得成功。经过八年的服务，他终于晋升为行政官员。1982年6月28日，尼尔森被调往肯蒂什镇（Kentish Town）就业中心分部，该分部距离他在马斯韦尔山的公寓大约三英里半。
His manager was a woman named Janet Lehman, and the two formed a close professional relationship that was the happiest of Nielsen's working career. Despite these positive changes, he continued to drink heavily, and within a couple of months, he resumed his old patterns. One September evening, Nielsen returned to his flat with 27-year-old Graham Allen. Graham was a Scottish-born heroin addict with a troubled past, who had moved to London in 1971 under the false lure of easy employment. Since then, he had spent years squatting in abandoned buildings, funding his drug addiction through a mix of government unemployment benefits, panhandling, and petty theft. Throughout the late 1970s and early 80s,
他的经理是一位名叫珍妮特·莱曼（Janet Lehman）的女性，两人建立了密切的工作关系，这是尼尔森职业生涯中最快乐的一段时光。尽管有这些积极的改变，他继续酗酒，并在几个月内恢复了旧习。一个九月的晚上，尼尔森带回了27岁的格雷厄姆·阿伦（Graham Allen）到他的公寓。格雷厄姆是一个出生于苏格兰的瘾君子，有着坎坷的过去，他于1971年带着轻松就业的虚假诱惑搬到了伦敦。从那时起，他花了多年时间在废弃建筑中非法占住，通过政府失业救济金、乞讨和轻微盗窃来资助他的毒瘾。在整个70年代末和80年代初，
he spent time in both rehab and prison, and when released, he escalated to robbing pharmacies. Graham was engaged in a long-running affair with a woman named Leslie, who was the girlfriend of a well-known local criminal, and the two had a young son together. One night in September 1982, Graham and Leslie had a frenzied argument. Graham was drunk and demanded that Leslie give him money to buy heroin. When she refused, he proceeded to punch himself in the face. Fearful of his increasingly violent behaviour, Leslie locked Graham out of her house, telling him to go away and never come back.
他在戒毒所和监狱里度过，刑满释放后，他开始升级为抢劫药店。格雷厄姆与一个名叫莱斯利（Leslie）的女人保持着长期的婚外情，莱斯利是当地一个知名罪犯的女友，两人育有一个小儿子。1982年9月的一个晚上，格雷厄姆和莱斯利爆发了一场疯狂的争吵。格雷厄姆喝醉了，要求莱斯利给他钱买海洛因。当她拒绝时，他开始疯狂地用拳头砸自己的脸。由于害怕他日益暴力的行为，莱斯利将格雷厄姆锁在门外，告诉他滚开，永远不要回来。
It's unclear where Graham and Nielsen met, or how Graham ended up at Nielsen's flat, but once they were there, Graham requested something to eat. Nielsen didn't have much food in the house except for a carton of eggs, so he made Graham a large omelet. When Graham was about three-quarters of the way through eating it, he suddenly fell asleep or passed out with a large piece of the omelet hanging out of his mouth. Nielsen couldn't tell whether Graham was still breathing or not, but he leaned forward and proceeded to strangle him. He later recalled, If the omelet killed him, I don't know, but anyway, in going forward, I intended to kill him.
目前还不清楚格雷厄姆和尼尔森是在哪里相遇的，或者格雷厄姆是如何落脚到尼尔森的公寓的，但一旦到了那里，格雷厄姆就要求吃点东西。尼尔森家里除了卡纸盒装的鸡蛋外没有什么食物，于是他给格雷厄姆做了一个大煎蛋。当格雷厄姆快吃完四分之三时，他突然睡着或昏迷过去，嘴里还挂着一大块煎蛋。尼尔森分不清格雷厄姆是否还在呼吸，但他探身向前，开始勒死他。他后来回忆道：“这个煎蛋是不是害死了他，我不知道，但总之，在扑过去的时候，我的确是想杀死他。”
An omelet doesn't leave red marks on a neck. I suppose it must have been me. The next day, Nielsen filled the bathtub with water and placed Graham's body inside it, before going to work as usual. He kept the body in the tub for three days, changing the bathwater on occasion. On the fourth day, he dismembered Graham's body, boiled several of the body parts, and then flushed the organs and some of the flesh down the toilet. He placed the rest of the remains into black plastic bags and stuffed them into the tea chest alongside the remains of John Howlett. Graham's girlfriend, Leslie, was used to him disappearing for long periods of time,
“一个煎蛋是不会在脖子上留下红印的。我想那一定是我干的。”第二天，尼尔森在浴缸里蓄满水，把格雷厄姆的尸体放了进去，然后像往常一样去上班。他把尸体放在浴缸里三天，偶尔更换洗澡水。第四天，尼尔森将格雷厄姆的尸体分尸，煮了几个身体部位，然后将内脏和部分肉冲进马桶。他把剩下的遗体装进黑色塑料袋里，塞进茶箱，和约翰·霍利特的遗体放在一起。格雷厄姆的女友莱斯利习惯了他长时间失踪，
but he always wrote her letters during his absence. After she failed to hear from him for several months, Leslie continued to hope that Graham was alive, but feared that he had actually passed away from an overdose. He was never reported missing. On Wednesday, December 22, 1982, Nielsen was drinking in a Soho pub when he met 20-year-old Trevor Simpson, who had just been released from prison after serving a six-month sentence for carjacking. The two began talking, and after a few drinks, Nielsen invited Trevor back to his flat. Trevor accepted, and the two went to 23 Cranley Gardens, where Nielsen told Trevor he was welcome to sleep in one of the armchairs in his living room. The next morning, he extended the offer,
但他失踪期间总会写信给她。在她几个月没有收到他的消息后，莱斯利仍然希望格雷厄姆还活着，但又担心他其实已经因吸毒过量而过世了。他从未被报失踪。1982年12月22日星期三，尼尔森正在苏荷区的一家酒吧喝酒，遇到了20岁的特雷弗·辛普森（Trevor Simpson），后者因劫车服刑六个月刚出狱。两人开始交谈，喝了几杯后，尼尔森邀请特雷弗回他的公寓。特雷弗接受了，两人来到了克兰利花园23号，尼尔森告诉特雷弗他可以在起居室的扶手椅上睡觉。第二天早上，他延续了这个邀请，
and Trevor stayed for several more days. Although he was happy to have a place to stay over Christmas, Trevor soon became frustrated with Nielsen, who continuously bombarded him with left-wing political rhetoric. He also noticed an awful odor that seemed to emanate from the flat, but wasn't inclined to search for the source of the smell. By Monday, December 27, Trevor had stayed at the flat for five days. Nielsen made them a stew to eat, but became irritated when Trevor made a rude remark about the taste. Later that night, Nielsen drunkenly muttered something about needing to consult with the professor about whether or not Trevor could stay any longer. Trevor went to bed shortly afterwards,
特雷弗又多住了几天。虽然很高兴能在圣诞节期间有个地方住，但特雷弗很快对尼尔森感到沮丧，因为他不断向他灌输左翼政治言论。他还注意到一股可怕的臭味似乎从公寓里散发出来，但并没有去寻找气味来源的意愿。到12月27日星期一，特雷弗已经在公寓里住了五天。尼尔森为他们做了炖菜吃，但当特雷弗对味道做出粗鲁的评价时，尼尔森变得十分恼火。那天晚些时候，尼尔森酒后嘟囔着说需要跟教授商量一下特雷弗是否还能继续住下去。特雷弗不久后上床睡觉，
but awoke at 1am to find the living room filled with smoke. He ran to the kitchen, where he found Nielsen calmly drinking a glass of water. The smoke was determined to be coming from a pair of jeans on the living room floor, which Nielsen said was likely caused by Trevor dropping a lit cigarette. The fire was extinguished without further incident, and Trevor stayed for one more night before moving on, with Nielsen saying he was welcome to return any time. A few days later, at around lunchtime on Friday, December 31, Nielsen visited a pub down the street from his flat. He returned home at 8pm and knocked on the door of his downstairs neighbors,
但在凌晨1点醒来，发现起居室里弥漫着烟雾。他跑进厨房，发现尼尔森正平静地喝着水。经确认，烟雾来自起居室地板上的一条牛仔裤，尼尔森称这可能是特雷弗扔下的烟头引起的。火被扑灭，没有引发进一步的事故，特雷弗又住了一晚便搬走了，尼尔森说他随时欢迎回来。几天后，即12月31日星期五午饭时间左右，尼尔森拜访了他公寓楼下的一家酒吧。他于晚上8点回到家中，敲了楼下邻居的门，
Vivienne McStay and Monique Van Rutter, to ask if they wanted to watch television with him upstairs. The women declined as they were in the middle of cooking dinner, and could also tell that Nielsen was very drunk. He seemed annoyed by their refusal, but invited them to join him at the local pub later that night to celebrate the new year, then went back upstairs. At around 11pm, Nielsen walked to the nearby Greenman pub, where he met a young Japanese chef named Toshimitsu Ozawa. The pub closed just after midnight, and the two decided to return to Nielsen's flat. Once they were inside, Nielsen calmly approached Toshimitsu with a necktie pulled totally between his outstretched arms.
维维安·麦克斯特伊（Vivienne McStay）和莫妮克·范·鲁特（Monique Van Rutter），问他们是否愿意上楼和他一起看电视。两位女士拒绝了，因为她们正忙着做晚饭，而且也能看出尼尔森喝得酩酊大醉。他对她们的拒绝似乎感到恼火，但邀请她们当晚晚些时候去当地酒吧一起庆祝新年，然后回到了楼上。晚上11点左右，尼尔森走到附近的“绿人”（Greenman）酒吧，在那里遇到了一个年轻的日本厨师小泽俊光（Toshimitsu Ozawa）。酒吧刚过午夜关门，两人决定回到尼尔森的公寓。一进屋，尼尔森便平静地走向小泽俊光，手里紧紧拉着一条横在双臂之间的领带。
At first, Toshimitsu thought Nielsen was joking, but when Nielsen repeated the action again, Toshimitsu realized Nielsen was serious. Terrified, Toshimitsu kicked Nielsen in the groin and fled from the flat, running down the stairs and into the night. The downstairs neighbors, Vivienne and Monique, heard arguing, followed by banging and the sound of someone sobbing. They ventured outside to see what was going on, only to find a highly intoxicated Nielsen on the stairs. Toshimitsu reported the incident to police, but felt it was too much trouble to follow through with the complaint, and subsequently withdrew it.
起初，小泽俊光以为尼尔森是在开玩笑，但当尼尔森再次重复这个动作时，小泽俊光意识到尼尔森是认真的。小泽俊光惊恐万状，一脚踢中尼尔森的裆部，逃出了公寓，顺着楼梯冲进了夜色中。楼下的邻居维维安和莫妮克听到了争吵声，接着是撞击声和某人的哭泣声。她们走到外面查看情况，却发现醉醺醺的尼尔森正站在楼梯上。小泽俊光向警方报告了这起事件，但觉得跟进投诉太麻烦，随后撤回了投诉。
Less than four weeks later, on Wednesday, January 26, 1983, Nielsen was walking through London's West End when he started chatting with a 20-year-old named Stephen Sinclair. Stephen, who had been born in Scotland and was adopted, had lived a hard life. Throughout his childhood, he struggled with severe personality problems, was afflicted by regular bedwetting, and often self-harmed. At the age of 12, he was diagnosed with psychomotor epilepsy, a disorder that impacts the brain's temporal lobe and impairs an individual's awareness to their surroundings. Stephen was subsequently institutionalized and placed into foster care, and by the time he was
不到四周后的1983年1月26日星期三，尼尔森正走在伦敦西区，这时他开始与一个名叫斯蒂芬·辛克莱（Stephen Sinclair）的20岁年轻人聊天。斯蒂芬出生于苏格兰并被收养，度过了艰难的一生。在整个童年时期，他一直在与严重的性格问题作斗争，饱受频繁尿床的困扰，并且经常自残。12岁时，他被诊断出患有精神运动性癫痫，这是一种影响大脑颞叶并损害个体对周围环境认知的疾病。斯蒂芬随后被送进收容机构并被寄养，到了
18, he was addicted to amphetamines and had contracted hepatitis B. He moved to London, where he lived in hostels or squatted in derelict houses, and spent most of his time loitering around Leicester Square. He was well known to social workers and police in the area, and had been imprisoned multiple times. Although he was generally regarded as a social outcast, Stephen had accumulated many friends on the streets of London, and was known to have a sensitive and friendly side. Nielsen sympathized with the troubled young man, and offered to buy him a meal from McDonald's. Some of Stephen's friends saw them walk off together, but didn't intervene in case Stephen was planning to rob Nielsen, which he was known to do.
18岁时，他已经对安非他命成瘾并感染了乙型肝炎。他搬到了伦敦，住在青年旅社或废弃房屋里，大部分时间都在莱斯特广场附近闲逛。他在当地的社工和警察中很有名，曾多次入狱。尽管他通常被视为社会边缘人，但在伦敦街头，斯蒂芬结交了许多朋友，并且以敏感和友善的一面而闻名。尼尔森同情这个陷入困境的年轻人，主动提出请他在麦当劳吃顿饭。斯蒂芬的一些朋友看到他们一起走开，但没有干预，以防斯蒂芬正计划抢劫尼尔森（他以前常这么做）。
The two ate, then stopped at a liquor store before deciding to head to Nielsen's flat. They caught the tube back to Muswell Hill, arriving at 23 Cranley Gardens at around 9 pm. The men drank, chatted, listened to music, and watched TV together. At some point during the evening, Stephen went to the bathroom to inject himself with what Nielsen assumed to be speed, but by the early hours of the morning, he had dozed off in one of the armchairs. Nielsen shook Stephen to see if he was awake, and when there was no response, he went into the kitchen and cut up an old necktie, which he tied with some string to fashion a ligature.
两人吃完饭，在一家酒类专卖店停了一下，然后决定前往尼尔森的公寓。他们坐地铁回到马斯韦尔山，于晚上9点左右到达克兰利花园23号。两个男人一起喝酒、聊天、听音乐、看电视。傍晚的某个时候，斯蒂芬去浴室给自己注射了尼尔森认为是安非他命的药物，但在清晨时分，他在其中一把扶手椅上打起瞌睡。尼尔森摇晃着斯蒂芬看他是否醒着，在没有得到回应后，他走进厨房剪下一条旧领带，用一些绳子将其系好做成了一个勒具。
Bleep followed him back into the living room wagging her tail, and Nielsen padded her before ordering her into the bedroom. He then proceeded to strangle Stephen, who slipped into unconsciousness without a struggle. When he stopped breathing, Nielsen said, Stephen, that didn't hurt at all. Nothing can touch you now. He later recalled, I remember wishing he could stay in peace like that forever. I had a feeling of easing his burden with my strength. I felt relieved that his troubles were now over. Nielsen removed Stephen's clothing and carried him to the bathroom,
“哔哔”摇着尾巴跟着他回到起居室，尼尔森抚摸了它一下，然后命令它回卧室。接着，他开始勒死斯蒂芬，后者在没有挣扎的情况下陷入了昏迷。当他停止呼吸时，尼尔森说：“斯蒂芬，一点也不疼。现在什么也伤害不了你了。”他后来回忆道：“我记得当时真希望他能永远这样平静下去。我有一种用我的力量减轻他负担的感觉。我感到很欣慰，他的烦恼现在终于结束了。”尼尔森脱掉斯蒂芬的衣服，把他抱到浴室里，
where he bathed him in the tub with lukewarm water and lemon-centred dishwashing liquid. Afterwards, he dried him and carried him to the bedroom, where he laid him down on the bed and propped one large mirror at the end of the bed and one by its side. Nielsen undressed and lay naked next to Stephen's body, covering both of them with talcum powder, so that their skin was a similar colour. He later told author Brian Masters, I spoke to him as if he was still alive. I was telling him how lucky he was to be out of it all. I thought how beautiful he looked and how beautiful I looked. He looked sexy, but I had no erection. He just looked fabulous. In another account, he recalled,
在温水和柠檬味洗洁精的浴缸里为他清洗。之后，把他擦干抱回卧室，让他平躺在床上，并在床尾和床侧各架起一面大镜子。尼尔森脱光衣服，赤身裸体地躺在斯蒂芬的尸体旁，在两人身上都涂满了爽身粉，这样他们的肤色看起来就很相似。他后来告诉作家布赖恩·马斯特斯（Brian Masters）：“我和他说话，就好像他还活着一样。我告诉他是多么幸运能摆脱这一切。我觉得他看起来是多么美丽，我自己看起来也多么美丽。他看起来很性感，但我没有勃起。他只是看起来棒极了。”在另一段陈述中，他回忆道：
I wanted to touch and stroke him, but did not. I lay naked beside him, but only looked at the two bodies in the mirror. I just lay there and a great peace came over me. I felt that this was it, the meaning of life, death, everything. No fear, no pain, no guilt. I could only caress and fondle the image in the mirror. I never looked at him, no sex, just a feeling of oneness. The next morning, Nielsen dressed Stephen in some of his own clean clothes, placed his body in the living room wardrobe and went to work. One week later, on Thursday, February 3, downstairs tenant Jim Allcock noticed that one of the toilets on the ground floor of 23 Cranley Gardens was blocked. He attempted to unblock it
“我想触摸和抚摸他，但没有。我赤身裸体地躺在他身旁，但只是看着镜子里的两具尸体。我就那样躺着，一种巨大的平静向我袭来。我觉得这就是全部，生命的意义，死亡，一切。没有恐惧，没有痛苦，没有内疚。我只能爱抚和抚摸镜子里的影像。我从未看他本人，没有性，只有一种合二为一的感觉。”第二天早上，尼尔森给斯蒂芬穿上他自己的一些干净衣服，把他的尸体放进起居室的衣柜里，然后去上班。一周后的2月3日星期四，楼下租户吉姆·奥尔科克发现克兰利花园23号底楼的一个马桶堵塞了。他试图用
using an acid solution and prodding sticks, but to no avail. The next morning, Jim's girlfriend Fiona Bridges bumped into Dennis Nielsen and asked if he was having any trouble with the toilet in his flat, and Nielsen replied that he wasn't. Jim phoned the building's estate agency, Ellison Co., to notify them of the issue and to ask for the number of a plumber. At 4.15pm, Fiona called the plumber, but he wasn't available, so she left a message with the details. Nielsen had spent the afternoon of Friday, February 4 drinking at the pub to prepare himself for the process of disposing of Stephen Sinclair's body. In the evening, he returned to his flat,
酸液和棍子去疏通，但徒劳无功。第二天早上，吉姆的女友菲奥娜·布里奇斯偶遇丹尼斯·尼尔森，询问他公寓里的马桶是否有问题，尼尔森回答说没有。吉姆打电话给该建筑的房地产代理公司埃利森公司（Ellison Co.）报告这个问题，并索要水管工的电话号码。下午4点15分，菲奥娜打电话给水管工，但对方不在，于是她留下了详细信息。2月4日星期五下午，尼尔森一直在酒吧喝酒，为处理斯蒂芬·辛克莱尸体的过程做心理准备。傍晚时分，他回到公寓，
lined the bathroom floor with garbage bags, and retrieved Stephen's body from the wardrobe. Using a carving knife, he dismembered the body and removed the organs. Employing the same technique he had used when disposing of John Howlett, he boiled various body parts to soften the tissue so that it would be easier to flush down the toilet. At this point, it hadn't occurred to Nielsen that the blocked toilets his downstairs neighbors were experiencing could be caused by his actions. Halfway through the task, he took a break to walk bleep to a nearby supermarket, where he purchased cigarettes and a bottle of rum. Upon returning home, he listened to classical music and drank heavily,
用垃圾袋铺满浴室地板，从衣柜里取出了斯蒂芬的尸体。他用一把雕刻刀将尸体分尸并取出内脏。他采用了处理约翰·霍利特遗体时使用的相同技术，将各种身体部位煮沸以软化组织，这样更容易冲进马桶。此时，尼尔森还没想到楼下邻居遭遇的马桶堵塞可能是由他的行为引起的。任务进行到一半时，他休息了一下，带着“哔哔”去附近的超市，买了香烟和一瓶朗姆酒。回到家后，他一边听着古典音乐一边痛饮，
while the body parts simmered on the stove. By midnight, he was too drunk to continue with the disposal, so he went to bed with Stephen's remains still in the living room and his head in a pot. The next day, Saturday, February 5, Nielsen woke with a hangover and spent most of the morning in bed. Unbeknownst to him, plumber Mike Welch arrived at around midday to inspect the drains from outside the property. Unable to clear the blockage himself, Mike determined it was a job for specialist plumbing company Dino Rod and a technician was booked for the next available appointment on Monday. Later that afternoon, Nielsen was leaving the house when his downstairs neighbor Fiona informed him of the plumbing situation and recommended that he avoid using
而身体部位则在炉子上炖着。到了午夜，他喝得太醉，无法继续处理，于是上床睡觉，斯蒂芬的遗体依然留在起居室里，头还在锅里。第二天，即2月5日星期六，尼尔森带着宿醉醒来，大部分早晨都在床上度过。他不知道的是，水管工迈克·韦尔奇（Mike Welch）在大约中午时分到达，从房产外部检查了排水管。由于无法自行清除堵塞，迈克认为这是专业管道公司“通渠鼠”（Dino Rod）的工作，技术人员被预约在下一个可用的时间——星期一。那天下午晚些时候，尼尔森正要出门，楼下的邻居菲奥娜告知了他水管的情况，并建议他避免使用
the toilet in his flat until the Dino Rod technician's visit in two days' time. Only then did it dawn on him that his flushing of body parts down the toilet had likely caused the blockage. He went to the supermarket to purchase cleaning products and air fresheners and returned to the flat to finish disposing of Stephen's remains. Later that evening, Nielsen's longtime friend Martin Hunter Craig paid him an unexpected visit. Nielsen only held the door open a fraction and told Martin he couldn't come in because he was with another visitor. Martin noticed that Nielsen seemed agitated and that his face was ghostly pale. There was also a strange vomit-like odor emanating from the flat.
自己公寓里的马桶，直到两天后“通渠鼠”的技术人员来访。直到那时他才恍然大悟，自己把尸体部位冲进马桶的行为很可能是导致堵塞的原因。他去超市买了清洁剂和空气清新剂，回到公寓继续处理斯蒂芬剩余的尸体。那天傍晚，尼尔森的老朋友马丁·亨特·克雷格（Martin Hunter Craig）对进行了一次不速之客的拜访。尼尔森只把门开了一条缝，告诉马丁他不能进来，因为他有别的访客。马丁注意到尼尔森显得很焦躁，脸色苍白如鬼。公寓里还散发出一股奇怪的、类似于呕吐物的气味。
At this point, Bleep noticed the door was partially open and ran outside and down the stairs. Nielsen instructed Martin to hold the door but warned him not to go inside and then chased after his dog. He returned with Bleep shortly after and asked for reassurance that Martin hadn't entered his flat. Martin assured Nielsen that he hadn't. Martin assumed that Nielsen had been drinking and didn't want him to go inside because there was someone there whom he was having sex with, so he left the property. Nielsen then spent the rest of Saturday night watching television. The following morning of Sunday, February 6, Nielsen divided Stephen's dismembered body parts and organs into multiple plastic bags and then placed these in two large garbage bags which
就在这时，“哔哔”发现门开了一条缝，跑了出去并顺着楼梯跑了下去。尼尔森命令马丁扶住门，但警告他不要进去，随后便追着他的狗去了。他不久后带着“哔哔”回来了，并要求马丁保证他没有进入他的公寓。马丁向尼尔森保证他没有。马丁以为尼尔森一直在喝酒，不想让他进去是因为里面有人在跟他发生性关系，于是便离开了这处房产。尼尔森随后把周六晚上的剩下时间用来观看电视。第二天早上，即2月6日星期日，尼尔森将斯蒂芬被分解的尸体部位和内脏分装进多个塑料袋中，然后将这些放入两个大垃圾袋里，
he stored in his wardrobe and under an upturned drawer in his bathroom. He covered the bags in his wardrobe with newspapers, stuffed several sticks of deodorant inside, and then locked the wardrobe doors. On Monday, February 7, Nielsen went to work as usual but spent the day on edge, knowing that the Dino Rod Technician was scheduled to visit and he would likely return home to find the police at his door. He was curt and irritable with his colleagues and apologised to one for his behaviour, explaining that he was under pressure. When he arrived at home, he was relieved to find that the Dino Rod Technician had never shown up. On Tuesday, February 8, Nielsen went to work again. That evening, Dino Rod Employee Mike
并把它们存放在衣柜里以及浴室翻转的抽屉底下。他用报纸盖住衣柜里的袋子，在里面塞了几个除臭剂条，然后锁上了衣柜门。2月7日星期一，尼尔森像往常一样去上班，但一整天都心神不宁，因为他知道“通渠鼠”的技术人员预定要来，他很可能会回到家发现警察在门口等候。他对同事显得生硬暴躁，并为自己的行为向其中一人道歉，解释说自己压力很大。当他回到家时，他松了一口气，发现“通渠鼠”的技术人员根本没有出现。2月8日星期二，尼尔森再次去上班。那天傍晚，夜幕降临时的晚上6点15分左右，“通渠鼠”员工迈克·
Katrin attended the property at approximately 6.15pm by which time night had fallen. Nielsen joined downstairs tenant Jim Allcock outside to watch as Mike lowered himself into the manhole to inspect the drains. Mike discovered the floating pieces of flesh and porridge-like substance and determined the blockage must have been caused by animal remains. He asked Nielsen if he had been flushing dog food down the toilet, to which Nielsen responded no, instead remarking that the flesh looked like pieces of Kentucky Fried Chicken. Mike concluded that something untoward was going on and phoned his manager, Gary Wheeler. The two men agreed to attend the property the next day so they could conduct a clearer inspection
卡特林（Mike Katrin）来到了这处房产。尼尔森和楼下租户吉姆·奥尔科克一起在外面观看迈克爬进检查井检查排水管。迈克发现了漂浮的肉块和粥状物质，并断定堵塞一定是由动物残骸引起的。他问尼尔森是否一直在往马桶里冲狗粮，尼尔森回答说没有，反而评论说这些肉看起来像是肯德基炸鸡。迈克推断有不寻常的事情正在发生，并打电话给他的经理加里·惠勒（Gary Wheeler）。两人同意第二天再次前往该物业，以便在白天进行更清晰的检查。
in daylight. When Nielsen returned to his flat, he wrote a letter to the building's management company, Ellison Co., to complain about the state of the drains. He spent the rest of the evening drinking heavily and that around midnight, he ventured outside and headed down into the manhole. He proceeded to clear as much of the flesh from the drain as he could, throwing the remains over the hedge into the back garden. In order to disguise the remainder of the drains' contents, he decided he would buy some Kentucky Fried Chicken in the morning and throw it into the mix. Downstairs tenants Jim and Fiona were awake and heard footsteps on the stairs,
当尼尔森回到他的公寓时，他给大楼的管理公司埃利森公司写了一信，投诉排水管的状况。他把剩下的傍晚时间用来大量饮酒，大约在午夜时分，他走到外面，下到了检查井里。他着手尽可能多地清理排水管里的肉块，把残骸扔过树篱扔进后花园。为了掩盖排水管里剩下的东西，他决定早上买点肯德基炸鸡扔进去。楼下的租户吉姆和菲奥娜醒了，听到了楼梯上的脚步声，
followed by the sounds of someone walking in the back garden and the manhole cover being removed. They also heard the repeated flushing of the toilet located on the landing. Jim armed himself with a pole and went out to investigate. Catching Nielsen as he was returning to his flat, his shirt slaves rolled up and a torch in his hand. When Jim asked his neighbor what he was doing, Nielsen explained that he had gone outside to urinate. The next morning of Wednesday, November 9, Nielsen left for work at around 8.30am. 45 minutes later, Dono Rod technician Mike Katrin and his boss Gary Wheeler arrived at 23 Cranley Gardens. Mike climbed down into the manhole for the second time and was surprised to see that
随后传来后花园里有人走动以及人孔盖被移开的声音。他们还听到平台上那间厕所连续冲水的声音。吉姆拿了一根杆子，出去查看情况。他恰好撞见正要返回自己公寓的尼尔森，当时尼尔森把衬衫袖子卷了起来，手里拿着一把手电筒。吉姆问邻居在干什么，尼尔森解释说他是出来小便的。第二天，即11月9日星期三，尼尔森大约在早上8点30分出门上班。45分钟后，Dyno-Rod管道疏通技术员迈克·卡特林（Mike Catrin）和他的老板加里·惠勒（Gary Wheeler）来到了克兰利花园23号。迈克第二次爬进人孔，惊讶地发现
most of the flesh-like substance was gone. Fiona Bridges, who was the only tenant at home, told Mike and Gary about the noises she and Jim heard the night before and how they had caught Nielsen sneaking around outside in the early hours. Mike continued to fish around in the drain until he pulled out what appeared to be a human knuckle along with more pieces of flesh and bone. Horrified at the discovery, Fiona immediately called the police. At 11am, a number of officers, led by 26-year veteran of the police force, Detective Chief Inspector Peter Jay, arrived at 23 Cranley Gardens. The police conducted a further search of the drain and retrieved several more pieces of flesh, each approximately four inches long and one inch wide,
大部分类肉物质已经不见了。菲奥娜·布里奇斯（Fiona Bridges）是家里唯一的租户，她把前一晚她和吉姆听到的噪声，以及他们如何在凌晨抓到尼尔森在外面鬼鬼祟祟的事情告诉了迈克和加里。迈克继续在下水道里摸索，直到捞出了一块看起来像是人类指关节的骨头，还有更多的肉块和碎骨。面对这一发现，菲奥娜感到震惊，并立即报了警。上午11点，由拥有26年警察生涯的侦探总督察彼得·杰伊（Peter Jay）率领的多名警官抵达了克兰利花园23号。警方对下水道进行了进一步搜查，找到了几块更多的肉，每块大约四英寸长、一英寸宽，
along with three small bones with a knuckle at each end. DCIJ personally took the remains to chairing Cross Hospital for examination by David Bowen, a professor of forensic medicine at the University of London, who also worked as a consultant pathologist. Professor Bowen declared that the small bones and knuckle had come from the hand of a human male and that the flesh was human neck tissue. The flesh also displayed a clear ligature mark, leading Professor Bowen to conclude that the victim had been strangled. As Nielsen's work day drew to an end, he tried to behave normally, but he knew an arrest was imminent and he would likely never return to the office again. Before he left, he wrote a note urging his colleagues not to believe any reports that
还有三块两端各带一个指关节的小骨头。DCI杰伊亲自将这些遗骸带到查令十字医院（Charing Cross Hospital），交由伦敦大学法医学教授、兼任顾问病理学家的大卫·鲍恩（David Bowen）进行检查。鲍恩教授宣布，这些小骨头和指关节来自一具男性人类的手，肉则是人类的颈部组织。这些肉上还显示出清晰的勒痕，这让鲍恩教授得出结论：受害者曾被勒死。随着尼尔森的工作日接近尾声，他试图表现得若无其事，但他知道逮捕即将来临，而且他很可能再也回不到办公室了。在他离开之前，他写了一张便条，敦促同事们不要相信任何
might emerge claiming he had taken his own life in jail. He tucked the note inside a draw, tidied his desk, and said a cheerful goodbye to his workmates. Some noticed he was wearing a blue and white football scarf, which was out of character as he typically wore drab, dark clothing. It would later be revealed that the scarf had belonged to his last victim, Stephen Sinclair. At 5.40pm, Nielsen arrived home to find three detectives, Detective Chief Inspector Peter J, Detective Inspector Stephen McCaskar and Detective Constable Jeffrey Butler waiting at the front door of the building. DCIJ introduced himself and explained that they were there to investigate
可能出现的声称他在狱中自杀的报道。他把便条塞进抽屉里，整理好办公桌，并兴高采烈地和同事们道别。一些人注意到他戴着一条蓝白相间的足球围巾，这与他通常穿着暗淡深色衣服的性格不符。后来人们发现，这条围巾属于他的最后一名受害者斯蒂芬·辛克莱（Stephen Sinclair）。下午5点40分，尼尔森回到家中，发现三名侦探——侦探总督察彼得·杰伊、侦探督察斯蒂芬·麦卡斯卡（Stephen McCaskar）和侦探警员杰弗里·巴特勒（Jeffrey Butler）——正等在大楼的前门。DCI杰伊自我介绍，并解释说他们是为了调查
the items found in the blocked drains. Nielsen feigned surprise and asked if the other two detectives were health inspectors. DCIJ explained that they were all police officers and wanted to ask him some questions. Nielsen led the three men upstairs to his flat, and once they were inside, DCIJ revealed that some of the objects in the drain had been identified as human remains. He then asked Nielsen, where's the rest of the body? Without hesitation, Nielsen calmly replied. In two plastic bags in the wardrobe next door, I'll show you. He led the officers into the living room and handed over the keys to unlock the wardrobe,
在堵塞的下水道里发现的物品而来的。尼尔森假装惊讶，问另外两名侦探是不是健康检查员。DCI杰伊解释说他们都是警察，想问他几个问题。尼尔森带着这三名男子上楼来到他的公寓，一旦进屋后，DCI杰伊就透露下水道里的一些物品已被辨认为人类遗骸。然后他问尼尔森：“身体的其他部分在哪里？”尼尔森没有犹豫，平静地回答道：“在隔壁衣柜里的两个塑料袋里，我带你们去看。”他带着警官们走进起居室，交出了打开衣柜的钥匙，
saying he wanted to tell them everything. DCIJ read Nielsen his rights, then placed him under arrest on suspicion of murder, although they still had no idea who the victim was. They led Nielsen to the police car, and as they drove towards Hornsey police station, one of the officers asked Nielsen whether they were dealing with one body or two. He replied, 15 or 16 since 1978, I'll tell you everything, it's a relief to get it off my mind. Nielsen initially declined to hire a lawyer and was held in custody while the police conducted a thorough search of his flat, recovering the remains of John Howlett and Graham Allen from the tea chest and Stephen Sinclair from the drawer in the bathroom. Two days later, at 10.45 am on Friday,
并说他想把一切都告诉他们。DCI杰伊向尼尔森宣读了权利，然后以涉嫌谋杀的罪名将他逮捕，尽管他们当时仍然不知道受害者是谁。他们把尼尔森带上警车，当他们驶向霍恩西（Hornsey）警察局时，其中一名警官问尼尔森他们处理的是一具尸体还是两具。他回答说：“自1978年以来有15或16具，我会把一切都告诉你们，这下如释重负了。”尼尔森最初拒绝聘请律师，并在警方对他的公寓进行彻底搜查期间被拘留，警方从茶箱中找回了约翰·霍利特（John Howlett）和格雷厄姆·艾伦（Graham Allen）的遗骸，并从浴室的抽屉里找回了斯蒂芬·辛克莱的遗骸。两天后，即周五上午10点45分，
February 11, the police conducted their first official interview with Nielsen. He admitted to the murders of the three men whose remains were found at 23 Cranley Gardens, and to a further 12 at his former residence on Melrose Avenue in Cricklewood. Police took Nielsen to the Melrose Avenue flat, where he showed them the two locations in the rear garden and surrounding wasteland where he had burned the bodies of his other victims. He also confessed to as many as seven other attempted murders. Police had a difficult task ahead of trying to formally identify the victims. Nielsen remembered few of their names and couldn't recall enough specific details
2月11日，警方对尼尔森进行了第一次正式讯问。他承认了在克兰利花园23号发现遗骸的三名男子的谋杀案，以及他在克里克伍德（Cricklewood）梅尔罗斯大道（Melrose Avenue）前住所发生的另外12起谋杀案。警方将尼尔森带到梅尔罗斯大道的公寓，他在那里向警方展示了后花园和周围荒地上的两个地点，他曾在那里焚烧其他受害者的尸体。他还承认了多达七起其他未遂谋杀案。警方面临着一项艰巨的任务，那就是试图正式确认受害者的身份。尼尔森记不清他们的名字，也记不清足够的具体细节
about each individual to provide an immediate identification. As it was 1983, DNA testing didn't yet exist and CCTV technology was still in its infancy, so the police had to rely on fingerprints, dental records, and the victim's personal items. This meant that they also had no choice but to depend on the assistance of Dennis Nielsen himself. Stephen Sinclair was the first to be identified. At the time of his death, the 20-year-old was wanted by police for some minor offenses, and his fingerprints were already on file. Forensic investigators found fingerprints on Stephen's leather jacket, a used syringe, and a tobacco tin, all of which were found in Nielsen's flat, and tested them against
来对每个人进行即时辨认。由于当时是1983年，DNA检测技术尚不存在，CCTV闭路电视技术也处于起步阶段，因此警方不得不依靠指纹、牙科记录和受害者的私人物品。这意味着他们也别无选择，只能依赖丹尼斯·尼尔森本人的协助。斯蒂芬·辛克莱是第一个被确认身份的人。在他死时，这名20岁的年轻人因一些轻微罪行遭到警方通缉，其指纹已经存档。法医调查人员在尼尔森公寓里发现的斯蒂芬的皮夹克、一支用过的注射器和一个烟草盒上找到了指纹，并将其与
the prints on file to confirm a match. At 5.45pm on February 11, Nielsen was officially charged with Stephen's murder. Under further advice from law enforcement, Nielsen retained the services of Ronald Moss, a middle-aged solicitor who had experienced dealing with lower-profile murder cases. During their first meeting, Nielsen took an immediate liking to Moss. Moss found Nielsen to be calm and rational and agreed to accept him as a client. The tabloid press had already been tipped off about the grim discovery at 23 Cranley Gardens by dyno-rod plumber Mike Catron, and were circling for further information so they could run a story. Within an hour of the formal charge being made, reporters managed to locate Nielsen's mother
档案中的指纹进行比对以确认相符。2月11日下午5点45分，尼尔森被正式指控谋杀斯蒂芬。在执法部门的进一步建议下，尼尔森聘请了罗纳德·莫斯（Ronald Moss），一位处理过低调谋杀案经验丰富的中年律师。在他们的第一次会面中，尼尔森立刻对莫斯产生了好感。莫斯发现尼尔森冷静而理性，并同意接受他为客户。小报记者已经通过Dyno-Rod管道工迈克·卡特林得到了克兰利花园23号发生可怕发现的风声，并四处打听更多信息以便发表报道。在正式起诉后的一小时内，记者们设法找到了尼尔森的母亲
Betty in Aberdeenshire, Scotland, and requested photographs of her son. Betty obliged on the basis they would be returned to her, but she later found out the photographs were sold for large sums of money, and she never got them back. That evening, Nielsen's friend, Martin Hunter Craig, was watching television when a news report revealed that body parts had been discovered in the drains of an apartment building in Muswell Hill. The name of the killer was withheld, but when the report showed an image of 23 Cranley Gardens, Martin realised that Nielsen must be responsible. He was shocked to think that he had been at the property just days earlier. By Saturday, February 12, the story was making
贝蒂（Betty），她住在苏格兰阿伯丁郡（Aberdeenshire），并索要她儿子的照片。贝蒂在这些照片会被退还给她的前提下答应了要求，但她后来发现照片被以巨额金钱出售，并且再也没有拿回来。那天晚上，尼尔森的朋友马丁·亨特·克雷格（Martin Hunter Craig）正在看电视，一条新闻报道称在马斯韦尔希尔（Muswell Hill）一栋公寓楼的下水道里发现了人体尸块。凶手的名字被隐去了，但当报道显示克兰利花园23号的画面时，马丁意识到尼尔森一定难辞其咎。他震惊地想到，自己几天前才刚去过那个地方。到2月12日星期六，这个故事已经成为
headlines across England and overseas. Although the full extent of the murders hadn't yet been revealed, reporters had already dubbed the Muswell Hill property the House of Horrors, and were referring to the killer as the Muswell Hill murderer. Police were still working around the clock to identify the remaining victims, and had released very minor details to the media, but journalists were working overtime in an attempt to get the best scoop. Members of the press surrounded the Hornsey police station, with some attempting to rig a microphone outside of DCIJ's first floor window to obtain inside information. A Japanese news crew even positioned themselves in a house opposite the station and used highly
英格兰及海外各大报纸的头条。尽管谋杀案的全貌尚未完全揭晓，但记者们已经把马斯韦尔希尔的房产称为“恐怖之屋”，并将凶手称为“马斯韦尔希尔杀手”。警方仍在夜以继日地工作以确认其余受害者的身份，并向媒体透露了极少量的细节，但记者们为了抢到头条新闻而在加班加点地工作。媒体成员包围了霍恩西警察局，一些人甚至试图在DCI杰伊一楼窗户外面架设麦克风以获取内部消息。一个日本新闻摄制组甚至将自己定位在警察局对面的一栋房子里，并使用高
sophisticated sound equipment to try to eavesdrop on police interviews with Nielsen. At 10am, Nielsen made his first appearance in the magistrates court, where the judge ruled that he be remanded in custody for three more days of questioning before further legal proceedings. Afterwards, when he was being escorted out of the courthouse and back to the waiting police car, Nielsen elected to walk out in full view of the press. He later explained that he didn't want to hide away by covering his face like a common criminal. Nielsen's mother participated in a television interview in which she stated, I just don't understand how this could go on, and nobody knowing anything. I mean, I don't know anything about the last 10 years of his life,
精密的录音设备试图窃听警方对尼尔森的讯问。上午10点，尼尔森在治安法院首次出庭，法官裁定将他還押候审三天，以便在进一步法律程序前进行更多的盘问。随后，当他被护送出法院返回等候的警车时，尼尔森选择在媒体的众目睽睽之下步行走出。他后来解释说，他不想像个普通罪犯一样遮遮掩掩地把自己藏起来。尼尔森的母亲参加了一场电视采访，她在采访中表示：“我只是不明白这怎么会发生，而没有人知道任何事情。我的意思是，我对过去10年他的生活一无所知，
and I can't see what was happening to him. Something must have happened to him, because it's not my dentist that's doing it, not the boy I knew that's doing these things. He's always my son, and that's why I want him to know we're all concerned about him. And I just hope he'll get some help to cope with the situation he's in. The police continued to question Nielsen, with detectives consciously trying to maintain a relaxed atmosphere in order to keep him talking. Although they were horrified and occasionally physically sick from the details he divulged, they feared that he would clam up if he felt he was under attack. Nielsen was unusually cooperative, offering details about each murder,
我也看不出他身上发生了什么。他身上一定发生了什么事，因为做这事的不是我的儿子，不是我认识的那个做这些事的男孩。他永远是我的儿子，这就是为什么我想让他知道我们都在关心他。我只希望他能得到一些帮助来应对他所处的困境。”警方继续盘问尼尔森，侦探们有意识地试图保持轻松的氛围，以便让他继续开口。尽管他们对他透露的细节感到震惊，甚至有时恶心想吐，但他们担心如果他觉得受到攻击，就会守口如瓶。尼尔森表现出奇地配合，提供了每起谋杀案的细节、
descriptions of the techniques he used, and helping to identify the victims. As author Brian Masters described in his book, Killing for Company, quote, Not only did Nielsen make no hindrance, but he positively swamped the detectives with information faster than they could seek it. He barely required questioning. He spoke in an almost unbroken autobiographical monologue as if to purge his conscience of a burden which he could no longer bear alone. Yet there were no irrelevant details, no digressions into personal life, no pleas for comfort or understanding. He admitted that he was astonished he had no tears for the people who had died at his hands. It soon became clear to the detectives that the
他所使用手法的描述，并协助辨认受害者。正如作家布赖恩·马斯特斯（Brian Masters）在他的书《伴伴谋杀》（Killing for Company）中所描述的那样：“尼尔森不仅没有设置障碍，而且积极地用信息淹没侦探，速度快得他们都来不及索取。他几乎不需要审讯。他几乎在进行一场不间断的自传式独白，仿佛是为了净化自己的良心，卸下一个他再也无法独自承受的沉重负担。然而，其中没有任何无关的细节，没有对个人生活的离题闲扯，没有对舒适或理解的恳求。他承认，他很惊讶自己竟然为死在自己手下的人流不出一滴眼泪。”侦探们很快发现，
number of people who visited Nielsen's flat without incident far outweighed those who came under attack or were killed. Nielsen rejected the suggestion that he intentionally sought out victims, claiming that he only ever went out in search of company and the attacks were never planned, quote. When I voluntarily go out to drink, I do not have the intention at that time to do these things. I seek company first and hope everything will be all right. Nielsen claimed to be relieved that he'd finally been caught, as he would have kept killing otherwise, and the detectives were convinced he never would have given himself up of his own accord. In a later interview for the television program
造访尼尔森公寓且安然无恙的人数，远远超过了那些遭到袭击或被杀害的人。尼尔森拒绝了自己是有意寻找受害者的说法，声称他外出只是为了寻找陪伴，袭击从未有过计划：“当我自愿外出喝酒时，我当时并没有做这些事的意图。我首先是寻找陪伴，并希望一切都会好起来。”尼尔森声称，对于终于被抓获感到如释重负，因为否则他会一直杀下去，而侦探们确信他绝不会自愿投案。在后来为电视节目
Britain's most evil serial killers, DCIJ recalled, Nielsen said if you hadn't have caught me now, it wouldn't have been 15, it would have been 150, and I think he might have been right. When the formal interviews were finally complete, Nielsen's solicitor Ronald Moss asked him why he had committed the crimes. Nielsen responded, quote. I am hoping you will tell me that. While the police and prosecution continued to gather evidence for trial, Nielsen was housed at Brixton Prison in the inner south of London. Upon his arrival, he was required to change into the standard prison-issued uniform of brown trousers and a blue striped shirt. And based on a psychiatrist's recommendation, he was placed in the prison's hospital wing for his own safety.
《英国最邪恶的连环杀手》进行的采访中，DCI杰伊回忆说：“尼尔森说，如果你们现在没抓到我，那就不会是15个，而会是150个，我想他可能是对的。”当正式讯问终于结束时，尼尔森的律师罗纳德·莫斯问他为什么要犯下这些罪行。尼尔森回答道：“我希望你能告诉我答案。”正当警察和控方继续搜集审判证据时，尼尔森被关押在伦敦南部内陆的布里克斯顿监狱（Brixton Prison）。他一到达，就被要求换上监狱统一发放的标准制服——棕色长裤和蓝白条纹衬衫。根据精神病医生的建议，为了他自身的安全，他被安排在监狱的医院病房里。
Nielsen was only allowed out of his cell to participate in supervised exercise for half an hour each day and was forbidden from associating with other prisoners. He was labelled a category A prisoner, which meant he posed the highest threat to police and the public, and was moved between souls every couple of days. Nielsen was also banned from attending the chapel, which upset him even though he was an atheist. Frustrated that the chaplains didn't stand up to the prison governor on his behalf, he labelled them Christian hypocrites, who were worse than cockroaches. With Nielsen incarcerated, his beloved dog Bleep was taken in by an animal rescue shelter in
尼尔森每天只被允许离开牢房半小时参加受监督的锻炼，并被禁止与其他犯人交往。他被列为A级犯人，这意味着他对警察和公众构成了最高威胁，并且每隔几天就会在不同的单人间之间转移。尼尔森还被禁止去小教堂，这让他很不高兴，尽管他是个无神论者。由于沮丧地发现神职人员没有替他向监狱长据理力争，他称他们为“比蟑螂还坏的基督教伪君子”。随着尼尔森入狱，他心爱的狗布利普（Bleep）被伦敦西南部的一家动物收容所收养，以便为其重新寻找归宿。但就在她到达一周内，她就病倒并死去了。她的死让尼尔森心碎，他后来向作家布赖恩·马斯特斯解释道：
southwest London to be rehomed. But within a week of her arrival, she became ill and passed away. Her death left Nielsen heartbroken, and he later explained to author Brian Masters, I am ashamed that her last days should be so painful. She had always forgiven me everything, and nothing but me could ever break her heart. She'd never let me down, but in the moment of her greatest crisis, I was not there. In prison, Nielsen soon became infatuated with a fellow inmate named David Martin, a small, effeminate career criminal who had spent his whole life in and out of jail. Martin was serving time for a spray of burglaries which resulted in him shooting a police officer, and later escaping from the magistrates court using pins he stored in his
“我为她的最后几天如此痛苦感到羞耻。她总是原谅我的一切，没有什么能像我一样击碎她的心。她从未让我失望，但在她遭遇最大危机的那一刻，我却不在场。”在监狱里，尼尔森很快迷恋上了一名叫大卫·马丁（David Martin）的同狱犯人，这是一个身材矮小、带有女性化特征的职业罪犯，一生大部分时间都在监狱进进出出。马丁因一连串入室盗窃而服刑，期间他枪击了一名警察，后来利用藏在长发中的发夹从治安法院逃脱。尼尔森和马丁几乎没有什么相处时间，只在运动场上偶尔见到对方。
long hair. Nielsen and Martin barely spent any time together, and only saw each other occasionally in the exercise yard. But Nielsen became upset when Martin was relocated to a different prison a few months later. In an attempt to maintain a semblance of a connection with Martin, Nielsen contacted Martin's solicitor Ralph Hyames to ask if he would consider representing him as a client. Hyames had a reputation for successfully defending notorious clients, so some also saw this as a tactical decision on Nielsen's behalf. He felt that his initial solicitor, Ronald Moss, was failing to help him stand up against the prison regime that he believed was working to bully him, and he had dismissed and rehired Moss three
但几个月后马丁被转移到另一所监狱时，尼尔森感到非常难过。为了维系与马丁的一丝联系，尼尔森联系了马丁的律师拉尔夫·海姆斯（Ralph Hyames），询问他是否会考虑接案成为自己的律师。海姆斯以为声名狼藉的客户成功辩护而闻名，因此一些人也将此视为尼尔森作出的战术决定。他觉得他最初的律师罗纳德·莫斯未能帮助他对抗他认为旨在欺负他的监狱体制，因此他已经解雇并重新雇用了莫斯三次。在尼尔森没有法律代表的那些时期里，他曾试图为自己辩护但没有成功。
times. During those periods where Nielsen had no legal representation, he had unsuccessfully attempted to represent himself. Hyames agreed to take Nielsen on as a client, but they soon butted heads. Nielsen accused Hyames of working too closely with the press, yet failing to use these opportunities to tell the public how poorly Nielsen was being treated in prison. Despite their disagreements, Hyames was able to convince Nielsen against pleading guilty to all charges, as he believed he could use the defense of diminished responsibility due to mental disorder. To pass the time in prison, Nielsen spent most of his days writing. He started working on an autobiographical manuscript titled History of a Drowning Boy, and also established a professional
海姆斯同意接下尼尔森这个客户，但他们很快就起了冲突。尼尔森指责海姆斯与媒体走得太近，却未能利用这些机会向公众讲述尼尔森在狱中遭受了多么糟糕的对待。尽管存在分歧，海姆斯还是说服了尼尔森不要对所有指控认罪，因为他相信可以利用精神障碍导致的责任减轻作为辩护理由。为了在狱中打发时间，尼尔森大部分时间都在写作。他开始着手撰写一本题为《一个溺水男孩的历史》（History of a Drowning Boy）的自传手稿，并与布赖恩·马斯特斯建立起职业合作关系，马斯特斯是一位以撰写英国贵族历史而闻名的作家。
relationship with Brian Masters, an author best known for his histories of the British aristocracy. Masters had developed an interest in the extremities of human behavior, and wrote a letter to Nielsen, asking if he would be open to cooperating on a book project. On March 30, 1983, Nielsen wrote to accept Master's invitation, opening the letter by saying, I passed the burden of my past actions onto your shoulders. The two began exchanging letters, with Masters also visiting Brixton Prison twice a week to speak with his subject. Nielsen didn't hold back, providing a comprehensive and in-depth account of his childhood, his time in the army, career problems, sexual fantasies, relationship
马斯特斯对人类行为的极端表现产生了兴趣，并写信给尼尔森，询问他是否愿意合作开展一个图书项目。1983年3月30日，尼尔森写信接受了马斯特斯的邀请，信的开头写道：“我把我过去行为的负担移交到你的肩上了。”两人开始互通信件，马斯特斯还每周两次访问布赖恩监狱与他的采访对象交谈。尼尔森毫无保留，提供了关于他的童年、军队生活、职业问题、性幻想、恋爱史以及每一桩谋杀案的全面且深入的记录。在写给马斯特斯的一封早期信件中，尼尔森写道：
history, and each of the murders. In an early letter to Masters, Nielsen wrote, I have led a strange life so far. Schoolboy, soldier, chef, projectionist, policemen, clerical officer, executive officer, drunk, sexualist, male and female, murderer, animal lover, independent trades union officer, debater, champion of social causes, do-gooder, disector of murder victims, grand vizier, and probably lifer. If there is a God, he must have a weird and jumbled sense of priorities. Job finder, peace campaigner, amateur filmmaker, mime of useless information, administrator, pen pusher, detained prisoner, solitary reaper, killer of the innocent, unremorseful, reformed character, enigma,
“到目前为止，我度过了奇怪的一生。小学生、士兵、厨师、放映员、警察、文职官员、行政官员、酒鬼、性欲者、男与女、杀人犯、动物爱好者、独立工会官员、辩论家、社会事业倡导者、慈善家、谋杀受害者解剖者、大维齐尔，可能还是无期徒刑犯。如果真有上帝，那他一定有一种怪异而混乱的价值观。寻工者、和平活动家、业余电影制作人、无用信息的模仿者、行政人员、推文牍者、被拘留的囚犯、孤独的收割者、无辜者的杀手、毫无悔意者、改过自新者、谜一样的人物，
now rapidly becoming a national receptacle into which all the nation will urinate, warp to monster, madman, ungodly, cold and alone. Nielsen told Masters about one incident in particular that had a profound impact on his life. In 1967, when he was stationed at Al-Mansura Detention Center in Yemen, he had been drinking heavily in town and hailed a taxi to take him back to the base. During the drive, he dozed off in the back seat and later woke with a sharp pain in the back of his head. He realized he was naked and had been struck over the head and placed into the boot of the car. Nielsen attempted to break free from the vehicle, which was still being driven,
现在正迅速成为一个国家容器，全国的人都将在里面小便，扭曲的怪物、疯子、不敬神者、冰冷而孤独。”尼尔森向马斯特斯讲述了一起对他的人生产生深远影响的特定事件。1967年，当他驻扎在也门的阿尔曼苏拉拘留中心（Al-Mansura Detention Center）时，他在镇上喝得酩酊大醉，叫了一辆出租车送他回基地。在车程中，他在后座上打瞌睡，后来醒来时感到后脑勺一阵剧痛。他意识到自己赤身裸体，头部遭到重击，并被塞进了汽车后备箱。尼尔森试图从这辆仍在行驶的车中挣脱，
but was unable to open the boot. After a short drive, the car stopped and Nielsen decided that his best chance to escape would be to play dead. The taxi driver got out, opened the boot, and started touching Nielsen, who tried to look as limp and lifeless as possible. The driver attempted to lift Nielsen out, at which point Nielsen's hand touched metal, and he realized there was a car jack handle close to him. He grabbed hold of it and delivered a hard blow to the taxi driver's head, immediately knocking him unconscious. Nielsen climbed out of the boot and struck the driver twice more in the skull. He saw that the car was parked in an isolated spot amidst the cluster of old buildings,
但无法打开后备箱。短暂行驶后，车停了下来，尼尔森决定他逃跑的最佳机会是装死。出租车司机下车，打开后备箱，开始触摸尼尔森，尼尔森则尽量装得瘫软而毫无生气。司机试图把尼尔森抬出来，就在这时，尼尔森的手摸到了金属，他意识到附近有一个汽车千斤顶手柄。他一把抓住它，狠狠地击中了出租车司机的头部，瞬间将其击晕。尼尔森爬出后备箱，又朝司机的头骨猛击了两下。他看到车停在一个孤立的地点，周围是一群老建筑，
so he wiped the jack handle clean and put it back in the boot, along with the driver. Then he quickly put his clothes on and walked to the detention center through the darkness. He was reprimanded for being delinquent but never said a word to anyone about his ordeal. Nielsen told Masters that the next morning he was filled with horror over the incident and started having nightmares about being tortured, raped, murdered, and mutilated. A psychologist later determined that Nielsen had fabricated this entire event. If that was the case, Masters believed that further proved just how powerful Nielsen's fantasies were. However, if the incident was true, Masters has pointed out that it demonstrated
于是他把千斤顶手柄擦拭干净，连同司机一起放回了后备箱。然后他迅速穿好衣服，在黑暗中走回拘留中心。他因行为不端而受到申斥，但从未对任何人吐露过自己这段恐怖经历半个字。尼尔森告诉马斯特斯，第二天早上他对这起事件充满了恐惧，并开始做关于被虐待、强奸、谋杀和肢解的噩梦。一位心理学家后来断定尼尔森完全捏造了这一事件。如果真是这样，马斯特斯认为这更加证明了尼尔森的幻想有多么强大。然而，如果这起事件是真的，马斯特斯指出它证明了
how successfully Nielsen was able to compartmentalize a horrific memory while outwardly appearing unaffected. Investigators continued the difficult task of identifying Nielsen's victims. Other than the human remains found at the Muswell Hill Flat, there was little physical evidence to go on, so they had to rely on Nielsen's recollections and missing person reports to join the dots. An operation room was set up and decked out with bulletin boards and blackboards, as well as poster-sized pieces of paper dedicated to each victim. On each poster, investigators listed as many details about the individual as possible, including their physical description, last known whereabouts, the date they were last seen,
尼尔森能够多么成功地将可怕的记忆隔离起来，而表面上看起来却毫无影响。调查人员继续进行确认尼尔森受害者身份的艰难任务。除了在马斯韦尔希尔公寓发现的人体遗骸外，几乎没有什么实质性证据可供依据，因此他们不得不依靠尼尔森的回忆和失踪人口报告来将线索串联起来。一个作战室建立起来了，里面装饰着公告板和黑板，还有专门针对每个受害者的海报大小的纸张。在每张海报上，调查人员列出了关于该个人的尽可能多的细节，包括他们的体貌特征、最后已知的行踪、最后一次被看到的时间，
and the date Nielsen claimed they were murdered. In addition to Steven Sinclair, police were eventually able to identify a total of seven other victims. The 28-year-old, who Nielsen knew only as John the Guardsman, was identified during a painstaking process in which police located every man with the name of John in the local area. Using a strip of muscle retrieved from Nielsen's flat, they determined the victim's blood type and used this to narrow down the list of unaccounted four Johns that matched the description Nielsen provided, finally identifying him as John Howlett. Martin Duffy, the 16-year-old catering student who Nielsen murdered in his Melrose Avenue flat, was identified using the chef's knives that Nielsen
以及尼尔森声称他们被谋杀的日期。除了斯蒂芬·辛克莱之外，警方最终成功确认了另外七名受害者的身份。28岁的约翰·霍利特（John Howlett）被尼尔森仅称为“卫兵约翰”，是在一项艰苦的过程中被确认身份的，当时警方在当地找到了所有名叫约翰的男子。利用从尼尔森公寓取回的一条肌肉组织，他们确定了受害者的血型，并以此缩小了未找到下落、且符合尼尔森提供描述的约翰名单，最终确认他就是约翰·霍利特。马丁·达菲（Martin Duffy）是尼尔森在梅尔罗斯大道公寓谋杀的16岁餐饮专业学生，警方通过尼尔森保留的、
had kept, which had Martin's name engraved on them. Kenneth Ockenden, the 23-year-old tourist who Nielsen had killed just days before his expected return to Canada, was identified when Nielsen was shown a photograph and recognised the young man. Kenneth's London Strict Directory was found amongst Nielsen's belongings, and forensic investigators were able to locate a partial fingerprint and match it against prints recovered from the belongings Kenneth had left behind in his hotel room. The family of 26-year-old Billy Sutherland, who had reported him missing in 1980, contacted police after seeing news about the murders and wondering whether Billy could have been a victim.
上面刻有马丁名字的厨师刀确认了他的身份。肯尼斯·奥肯登（Kenneth Ockenden）是23岁的游客，在预期返回加拿大几天前被尼尔森杀害，警方在向尼尔森展示照片时，他认出了这个年轻人。肯尼斯的伦敦斯特里特指南（London Street Directory）在尼尔森的物品中被找到，法医调查人员得以找到一枚部分指纹，并将其与肯尼斯留在酒店房间里的物品上提取的指纹进行比对。26岁的比利·萨瑟兰（Billy Sutherland）于1980年被报失踪，他的家人在看到关于谋杀案的新闻后联系了警方，想知道比利是否可能是受害者。
Nielsen was shown a photograph of Billy and recognised him as one of the men he had killed in his Melrose Avenue flat. Human remains were found under the floorboards in Nielsen's old flat, and forensic investigators were able to confirm Billy's identity from false teeth and a piece of skin with one of his tattoos on it. Also identified was 24-year-old Malcolm Barlow, who Nielsen strangled in his Melrose Avenue flat the day after Malcolm was discharged from hospital. Paul Nobs, the 19-year-old university student who Nielsen attempted to strangle in his sleep soon after moving into the Cranley Gardens flat, was identified as a survivor, as was 26-year-old Scotsman Douglas Stewart, who had fought off an attack at Melrose Avenue on November 10, 1980.
尼尔森被展示了一张比利的相片，并认出他是自己在梅尔罗斯大道公寓杀害的男子之一。警方在尼尔森旧公寓的地板下发现了人体遗骸，法医调查人员通过假牙和一块带有他纹身的皮肤确认了比利的身份。同时被确认身份的还有24岁的马尔科姆·巴洛（Malcolm Barlow），尼尔森在马尔科姆出院的第二天在梅尔罗斯大道公寓将其勒死。保罗·诺布斯（Paul Nobs）是19岁的大学生，在搬进克兰利花园公寓后不久在睡梦中被尼尔森企图勒死，他被确认为幸存者；26岁的苏格兰人道格拉斯·斯图尔特（Douglas Stewart）也是如此，他曾在1980年11月10日在梅尔罗斯大道击退了一次袭击。
On May 26, 1983, Nielsen's committal hearing commenced in the Old Bailey, the Central Criminal Court of England and Wales. The judge determined the prosecution had enough evidence to put Nielsen to trial for the murders of Stephen Sinclair, John Howlett, Billy Sutherland, Martin Duffy, Kenneth Ockenden and Malcolm Barlow, and for the attempted murders of Paul Nobs and Douglas Stewart. The trial was scheduled to commence in October, 1983. From the beginning of Nielsen's time in custody, he was required to wear the standard-issue prison uniform. This enraged him as he hadn't yet been convicted of a crime. He protested against it by walking around his cell naked. In response, the guards restricted him from leaving his cell entirely,
1983年5月26日，尼尔森的移交听证会在英格兰及威尔士中央刑事法院——老贝利（Old Bailey）开庭。法官裁定检方拥有足够的证据，就斯蒂芬·辛克莱、约翰·霍利特、比利·萨瑟兰、马丁·达菲、肯尼斯·奥肯登和马尔科姆·巴洛的谋杀案，以及对保罗·诺布斯和道格拉斯·斯图尔特的未遂谋杀案对尼尔森进行审判。审判预定于1983年10月开始。从尼尔森被拘留的一开始，他就被要求穿统一发放的监狱制服。这让他怒不可遏，因为他当时尚未被判罪。他通过赤身裸体在牢房里走来走去来抗议。作为回应，看守们限制他完全离开牢房，
which meant he was unable to empty his toilet bucket. On August 1, when Nielsen's bucket was full to the brim, he yelled, stand clear, and proceeded to throw its contents through the bars of his cell and onto the landing. Several guards were hit with the mass, and Nielsen was beaten in retaliation and given 56 days in solitary confinement. As Nielsen's time on remand went by, he began to express regret for committing the crimes. In a letter he sent to detectives thanking them for their professionalism when unravelling the case, Nielsen wrote, My remorse is of a deep and personal kind, which will lead a way inside me for the rest of my life.
这意味着他无法倒马桶。8月1日，当尼尔森的桶装得满满的时，他大喊一声“闪开”，并接着把里面的东西透过牢房的铁栏杆泼到了平台上。几名看守被排泄物击中，尼尔森为此遭到报复性殴打，并被判处56天单独关禁闭。随着尼尔森在押时间的推移，他开始对犯下的罪行表达悔意。在写给侦探的一封信中，他感谢他们在侦破案件时表现出的专业精神，尼尔森写道：“我的悔恨是深沉而个人的，它将伴随我的余生在我内心里燃烧。
I am a tragically private person, not given to public tears. The enormity of these acts has left me in permanent shock. The evil was short-lived, and it cannot live or breathe for long inside the conscience. I have slain my own dragon, as surely as the press and the letter of the law will slay me. To be continued next week There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是一个极其内向的人，不习惯在公众面前流泪。这些行为的巨大严重性使我陷入永久的震惊之中。这种邪恶是短暂的，它无法在良知内部存活或呼吸太久。我已经斩杀了内心的恶龙，就像新闻界和法律条文必将斩杀我一样。”下周未完待续此剧集尚无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。